look I I know I sang a little bit me in
charge of that Little Mermaid when I'm
not even gonna try and sing Queen so not
exactly a timely review this one but
I've now seen Bohemian Rhapsody and it's
probably the only movie aside from Black
Panther that's up for a bunch of
majoring Oscars that I'm gonna get to
see before the Academy Awards happen so
yeah why not talk about it so this part
of the reason I didn't get to this
sooner was it's not always easy for me
to get to the movies a lot in my local
movie theater only has three screens if
I have to go somewhere else sometimes
timing doesn't work out things that life
happens that's part of it and the other
thing was with this particular one was
my partner Liz also wanted to see it so
we wanted to see it together which of
course makes it even harder to
coordinate sometimes but we have now
actually seen it cuz now you know it's
rentable so Bohemian Rhapsody is
obviously the story of both Queen the
band and Freddie Mercury the individual
and I do feel it is worth saying both
because even though the emphasis at
least as far as the life story is on
Freddie the there there is quite a bit
in there about the band as a whole the
other care the other band members get a
bit of time obviously there's a ton of
the music in this so I wasn't sure how
it was gonna feel about this I'm not in
general I am NOT a big fan of biopics
just has a genre I feel like inherently
the problem with most biographical films
is that a lot of them make the decision
to try and cover big swaths of
somebody's life and just narrative ly
that's not what you would do I think the
reason most biographical pictures fail
is because you don't make them in the
way you make any others your honor
film because any other genre of film you
know you you look at the initial script
and go why is there all this stuff about
you know before you know the band even
forms and why are we even dealing with
the other days of the band like the
heart of the story is this section why
do we have all this other stuff but you
stick it in there and a biographical
picture because well that was part of
his life and so I think structurally a
lot of them just fall apart from me for
that reason because I think the fact
that it's a true story is often used as
a crutch especially considering how much
of this stuff gets changed anyways so
yeah I was a little bit nervous because
I like Queen I like Queen a lot Queen is
one of my favorite bands if I'm being
completely honest but I really liked
this and that was also doubly surprising
because I'd seen more than a few people
including some online critics who I
really like and respect not caring for
the movie and pointing out some serious
storytelling flaws or technical issues
like editing being really wonky and some
of the scenes and things like that and
I'm not gonna dispute things like that
but here's what I'll say I'm really good
and I might need to think about doing
this more often if I think I can
normally what I do a review I have a
tendency to do it within a few hours of
my having seen whatever the thing is in
this case I'm recording this too two or
three days after I saw it two days there
we go
two days after I saw it and that's
actually given me made me more kind to
it because what I'm left with at this
point is the technical flaws of it which
I can acknowledge have kind of faded in
my memory and what I'm left with when I
think about the film is great music
charismatic performers not only from the
lead Remy Malick who is phenomenal as
Freddie Mercury and what feels like a
story worth telling so I think I I'm not
sure that I'm gonna
like gonna start defaulting to reviewing
these a few days later and also there's
some films that are like if I don't talk
about them quick the details are gonna
fade from my head because they were so
unmemorable usually that's if I got a
rant about something but with something
like this its successes are rooted in
how it makes you feel as opposed to the
technical nuts and bolts of the
filmmaking which is not really
exceptional it's not awful I don't think
but it's not the best in the world not
by any means so I think in terms of like
the accolades that it's getting I get
why the rally Malick deserves a
nomination I'm not sure the film does as
a whole but that's not to say that the
film isn't good because I do think
especially if you like Queen that the
film is worth watching and I actually I
was impressed at how much wasn't
streamlined or minimized out of it bill
I was expecting like nothing more than
minimal acknowledgement at the fact that
he's Percy and he was born in Zanzibar
and I feel like that's something that
like a lot of people don't even have an
awareness of and it was nice to see that
like right off the bat one of the first
things we get about him as a character
which was pretty cool there's also his
relationship with the character of Mary
that I thought was really interesting
and again I'm not gonna speak to the
accuracy of this because I I don't know
in the amount of research I'm prepared
to do to find out how accurate it was or
wasn't is very limited so let me just
make very really clear if anyone doesn't
like this movie because of the
alterations it makes to the facts I yeah
I'm not even gonna argue with you on
that but in terms of the film as a
self-contained thing his dynamic with
Mary was really fascinating and I
thought really quite touching because he
really did care about her but at the
same time was not able to love her in a
way that she kind of needed in her life
yet at the same time he was envious of
the people who could love her in that
way and there's a lot of emphasis on how
lonely Freddy is and some of that they
do sort of they at least I felt that the
film did a good balancing act of not
making it seem like he was lonely
because of his sexuality but how his
sexuality at the time in which he was
living fed into his loneliness I think
at least for me and my takeaway I I
thought it did a good job of balancing
that so that it wasn't equate ingest you
know not being straight with being a
lonely unhappy person it it didn't feel
like it was doing a one-to-one with that
which I appreciated seeing some of the
you know creative stuff behind the songs
was well I think that if there was if
there was something that was cringy it
was probably Mike Myers as part as an
EMI executive who I think I did read
didn't even exist he's like a proxy for
a guy who did exist but he's
exaggerating for the sake of a joke and
so that they could have Mike Myers
famous for being Elaine in Wayne's World
head-banging to Bohemian Rhapsody tell
Freddie Mercury and Queen we can't
release both me and Rhapsody as a single
because people can't bang their heads in
the car to it like that that that was
cringe right there that that was
unnecessary and it didn't help and it
and honestly the film kind of ground to
a halt so that they could have that
scene that's that's like one of the few
criticisms that I had at the time
watching it that stuck with me because
thinking back on I can think of a number
of things or at least I can remember
thinking a number of things that weren't
lining up and weren't clicking for me as
I was watching but the thing is at this
point a couple days later I can't
remember what those were and even like
what they might have related to what I'm
left with overwhelmingly is the stronger
feeling and I think the saw the film
does use the songs of Queen quite well
especially in the climax the performance
at Live Aid is basically serves as the
climax of the film and I think that is
done really really wonderfully and I
think the the buildup
to it the catharsis of it the
performance of it it makes it feel
triumphant and it really is I think a
good point to choose to bring the
narrative to a close the one other thing
that's sort of a bit of an elephant in
the room issue with this film that I
will address insofar as I don't want to
deal with it more specifically is the
director this film was is officially
credited to Bryan Singer which brings
with it two really loaded issues the
first is the guy right now is buried in
some very unpleasant scandals and
actually he had been even before taking
this on um it just got worse since then
and but even beyond that it's debatable
how much of this film he actually shot
as far as the Directors Guild is
concerned he shot enough of the film
that he gets to keep his name on the
credits but apparently he literally just
stopped showing up to the set at some
point and somebody else took over and
directed the rest of the film
now exactly exactly what percentage of
that was how much of when Bryan Turner's
stop showing up was you know lower end
stuff like did he finish working with
the main cast I have no clue not I not a
clue but between those two things I just
kind of don't want to deal with talking
about Bryan Singer like just as a person
cuz and also you know how much he had to
do with this movie anyway what I will
say is it does it feels like a singer
film it has that balance of an ensemble
which I do think because Bryan Singer I
think is a very inconsistent director in
terms of putting out good movies and a
lot of even his better movies haven't
aged well but what I will say is he is
usually pretty good at balancing an
ensemble and knowing how to give us
enough of characters who are clearly not
the main character where they still feel
fleshed out
you know he was able to do that with the
x-men movies he did he was able to do
that with the usual suspects I do think
that's one of the few things he is
genuine I can you say he's genuinely
consistently good at and I do think that
is at play here because while this is
very much Freddie Mercury's movie none
of the other characters feel ancillary
or underdeveloped they feel like proper
people even though they are very much
not the focus so ultimately I'm not
gonna say like rush out and see this I'm
not even gonna say you must see the
performance of Remy Malick I say if you
are a fan of Queen I think that you will
enjoy this barring any issues of you
know the actual history of Queen enough
that any deviation is going to distract
or annoy you that might be more of a
deal breaker hard for me to say because
as I said exactly how much they did
deviate I don't really know but I'm
gonna wrap it up there um
Remy Malick maybe deserves to win Best
Actor I'm not gonna say that
definitively cuz I haven't really seen
anybody else who's up for it but I will
say the film doesn't deserve to win Best
Picture
I am glad he's nominated though and I
think the film yeah I think it deserved
the success that it had it may be
getting over praised in some circles but
no solid work I say so
believe me and Rhapsody what you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff to do
buttons links patreon hey I'm beggin now
I'm not really begging but you know it's
helpful there's others links down there
besides for you to check out plus you
know all these I got appeal box all that
stuff it's all down in the description
give it a look or don't you don't have
to it's okay cuz at the end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]